Yatim Beckman says bread is life that's
why he only puts home ground flour from
organic locally grown grains in his
bread water comes from his own spring
and additives are strictly for Bowden
one of berlin's biggest bakers of
organic bread Beckman says his
commitment is based on a philosophy of
life that applies to his business to
solar energy collect rainwater our
buildings are insulated and we use waste
heat we can also show you an
environmental balance sheet
demonstrating that since 1981 we've been
lowering our emissions continually and
even have a co2 neutral operation at the
moment every night some 8,000 loaves of
bread are baked at beckmann's his
customers include major supermarkets
hotels and organic food shops Beckman
says it's possible to combine a green
lifestyle commitment to sustainability
and business success ultimately it's a
sustainable business model customers are
more aware and critical and want to know
what they're supporting when they buy
something do they want to support
Monsanto we're regional business
structures and local trades do they want
to back Nestle or do something for the
farmers in their region one in yellow
egg Orno districts Germany's Green Party
relies on voters like Beckman people who
are idealistic successful and ready to
share the party is planning higher taxes
for better earners and a one-time levy
on assets greater than 1 million euros
they say everyone would profit from that
especially the middle classes descent
gunaji lot of those are precisely the
people who depend on public
infrastructure that works schools that
perform well gymnasiums with sound roofs
and intact public swimming pools that's
what we're trying to achieve it's not
about giving the state more money it's
about rectifying a situation in which
we've got extremely high growth in
wealth on the one hand and on the other
a
eight that's becoming increasingly
impoverished did a start in Miami vote
the urban middle class is one of the
Green Party's best sources of support
many earn above average incomes and
think organic food and sustainable
consumption are worth paying for the
Greens conclude they're also willing to
pay taxes to as long as they're used to
promote sustainable policies myson the
most think that we can afford things in
this category especially if they're
spent on sensible things namely for more
investment in education and working
infrastructure oh no no Phaneuf do you
informed the Greens 2013 election
campaign will be one based on social
issues which in Germany have
traditionally been leftist territory
some green party members say they're
worried that could frighten off some
voters we need investment in education
and climate protection and we've got to
approach major asset holders but we
can't bird in the middle class too much
I'm skeptical about a wealth tax it
means lots of paperwork and could reduce
the fixed assets of small and mid-sized
firms if we can't avoid that I'd drop
the policy the greens are via mentally
debating these issues a one-time levy on
assets over 1 million euros is
especially controversial many say it's
anti-business and erodes smaller
companies at their base the ring party
leadership says that's a
misinterpretation this obstinacy are not
taxing company space assets people are
insisting on things that are already in
the party's draft programme of
initiative yachting Beckman's bakery is
a mid-sized company that employs 60
people politically Beckman is a
committed green voter higher tax rates
on top income brackets attacks on assets
and other green tax plans could affect
his company directly despite that the
green businessman says he'll vote his
conscience because it's the sustainable
path good I'm honest either you're
politically credible or you're not that
also means that those who are better off
must show solidarity with the less
fortunate we're trying that on every
level it means paying taxes and
redistributing wealth
this provided awesome super tired
declan's organic bread is more expensive
because of how it's made but quality has
its price that's the message some say
the greens are trying to sell to the
voters as well